whenever something big happens on
Twitter black Twitter always has a
reaction black Twitter is a thing it's
huge okay huge and huge and and when
black Twitter Goes Ham everybody reacts
so right now ladies and gentlemen I got
somebody that you want to hear from our
next guest please welcome black Twitter
himself Twitter right to see you man
while you're doing gentlemen how you
doing man always blessing of a stress
even if the lord gave me less I know
that's right black Twitter's in the
building
indeed yeah all right well question
number one can you tell the people that
don't understand why we need black
Twitter regular Twitter is always
showing [ __ ] that black people don't
care about like you know white girls
with flat asses trying to twerk you got
people trying to justify the
Insurrection up and down Twitter and you
got clips from that boring ass shoulder
Crown it's a little Drive I don't want
to see it only Crown black people care
about is Crown Roy I heard that and not
Apple either the regular one no no so
you can put your clippers in the bag
it's actually true
condoms when I was younger oh my God
can't even just hit me hit just hit you
know who black Twitter look like what's
the guy what's the god uh from The Wire
the the guy Davis Clayton Clay Davis you
in the goddamn building hey jeez my name
is black Twitter I'm here to talk about
black Twitter I could proceed
we're just giving you [ __ ] upstairs
about the black diaspora on social media
that's right let's get back to the
dashboard if ain't nobody gonna talk
about it we will talk about it you know
uh listen what I want you to do is let
these people know what kind of content
is on black Twitter I mean there's a lot
of different things on black Twitter
there's you know trendy dances of course
there's soul food recipes for the
holidays how to legally avoid paying
debt how to hide money from the
government and of course hilarious clips
of Family Feud hilarious Clips very
funny yes yes very popular now yeah
Steve Harvey great but shout out shout
out to Steve uh now I have a non-black
friend and he joined black Twitter oh
for sure for sure as long as they're
named doesn't end in an ER we're talking
Connor Tucker Tanner Candace Owens
hey you know what man uh you know you
need some white people on black Twitter
right the reason why so you can ask them
questions like uh do white people have
cousins I don't know I just don't know
these are good points you make brother
Kevin and I think that we need people of
all Races on black Twitter which is why
we allow people of all Races got it on
black Twitter but only if they can
answer a couple of qualifying questions
okay do you wash your chicken with soap
do you shower your legs when you shower
I gotta get the legs can you name at
least four members of New Edition yeah
what color is Jesus and is R Kelly
innocent oh come on now the last one
that's not fair that's easy nobody
thinks R Kelly is innocent I know that
but if they say yes he is then I know
they just trying to kiss my ass that's
true that's very true it's the Trap
here's a question for you all who was
the fifth member
of Jodeci
[ __ ] staff member
I want to say Dewan
Casey JoJo Devonte Gavin there's one
more member of you did you say Gavin or
Dalvin you know the one yeah
the fifth member and then there was one
more of Joe
all right big girl big girl cocaine
cocaine God damn
yeah yeah
it was on the tip of my nose I was gonna
say it I was about to say I made a
valuable part in that group success uh
last question Elon Musk pay 44 billion
dollars for Twitter right how much would
you sell black 1500 see that's okay
that's quick that was a quick 1500 come
on you worth more than that don't you
think yeah I'm worth more than that but
I need I need rent money right now I
feel you I feel you all right well black
Twitter everybody black Twitter
hang out
oh
yeah
[Music]